thank you very much
it is a pleasure to be here
very happy to be here today I want to
talk about a couple initiatives going on
in our in the neighboring state here
Rhode Island related to pre exposure
prophylaxis prep as well as some other
HIV prevention initiatives and how they
all tied together so my ejectives today
I want to talk about prep I'm going to
talk about some HIV and STD testing as
well and talk about some the role of
implementation in our state I'm in the
third year of a k23 Mike a 23 through
Nyad and it focuses on HIV prevention in
Rhode Island it actually involves some
molecular epi work which I'm not going
to be talking about today the main focus
is HIV prevention for full disclosures
we did get a small grant from Gilead
Sciences and I'm going to talk about
that implementation project and we also
get funding from the Rhode Island
Department of Health so part of what I'm
going to talk about today is STDs and
then and prep in the setting of an STD
so I want to pose a question to the
audience whether that's an icebreaker
don't shout out the answer quite yet the
question is what is the most common STD
in the United States now I don't know
many people in this room of course but
one thing that I'm very passionate about
is march madness and so let's see cut
off the top of my slide here so okay
with the show of hands going down the
brackets here which STD is more common
in the United States in terms of number
of new diagnoses HIV or gonorrhea how
many people say HIV I think everyone
already saw the answer so we'll skip
hepatitis B or human papilloma virus
that causes cervical cancer how many
people say hepatitis B a couple hands
HPV a lot more hands and you are correct
chlamydia and syphilis which one is more
common chlamydia or syphilis how many
people say chlamydia how many people say
syphilis a couple chlamydia and human
herpes simplex virus or trichomonas how
many people say herpes simplex virus
good how many people say trichomonas
it's about 5050 so trichomonas is the
most common it gets harder
gonorrhea and HPV how many people say
gonorrhea okay a few percent HPV
majority you're correct HPV about
chlamydia and trichomonas this one's a
little bit harder how many people say
chlamydia how many people say
trichomonas almost 5050 it's actually
chlamydia and HPV and chlamydia who is
the winner how many people say HPV how
many people say chlamydia good so it's
actually HPV and this is really an
under-recognized STD in the country it's
estimated about eighty percent of people
of sexually active adults we require
this before the age of 50 just an FYI
i'm not going to talk about HPV today
but that's just a no and here's the data
if you don't believe me it's it's
available on the CDC website okay so
today I want to talk about pre exposure
prophylaxis and just sort of understand
where we are at the current time I am
going to briefly review some of the
studies have people had speakers before
about pre exposure prophylaxis okay a
little bit so I'm going to go through
these a little bit quickly so in the
summer 2012 the FDA recommended to not
fear emtricitabine which is truvada has
proved as prep prep a single pill for
HIV negative people to prevent HIV
infection so a single pill that people
can take to prevent HIV infection and
when we look at the six major studies
that have been done that have shown prep
efficacy they're listed here the authors
of the studies and you could look them
up if you wanted are in the parentheses
there the I prex the partners the tdf
the femme prep the voice and the Bangkok
to Navi r study so these sticks studies
were really based from around the globe
when you look at where they were where
they were centered on really only one of
them the I prec study was centered in
the United States or had sites in the
United States the two sites in the
united states were san francisco and
boston road at fenway community health
but the rest of the studies were really
looking at other highly highly HIV
prevalence settings such as Africa and
Southeast Asia when you look at the
people enroll in these studies it was a
very diverse makeup so again the I prec
study was only one that specifically
looked at men who have
with men as well as franchise from chin
transgender women the other studies
tended to look at heterosexual males and
females in the partners and prep looked
at zero discordant couples when you look
at what drug was used in in the studies
the majority were using truvada to knock
the very interested to mean versus
placebo of note the Bangkok turn off of
your study which was a major study pant
published in Lancet last year look into
injection drug use they only used to
Nava veer alone so that are using
basically one half of the drug
combination when we look at the efficacy
of prep the first study that came out
2010 I prex showed that had a forty-four
percent overall efficacy and this was
the intention-to-treat analysis which
means that it looked at all comers in
the studies right so these were people
that didn't necessarily take the drug
there are people that fell out as long
as they were initially randomized to the
drug versus placebo arm when you look
across the other studies it's it's clear
that there's about 60 or 70 there's a
sixty or seventy percent efficacy across
the other two major studies partners
prep and tdf and then the ID you study
in Bangkok showed about a fifty percent
efficacy and that was using to Nava ver
alone there are a couple major themes
but came out of all these trials and the
biggest one was really adherence I'm
going to talk about this for a little
bit if you look at the people who had
detectable drug levels so you know that
these people were actually taking the
drug it's thought that the efficacy of
prep is much higher it approaches eighty
to ninety percent so when you look at
the I prec study for the people actually
had detectable drug levels it's shown
that the the truvada the the prep was
about ninety two percent effective in
preventing HIV transmission so you can
see this sort of dichotomy between the
overall as well as a lot as people who
are truly adherent and in fact there
were two studies the femme prep in the
voice study that didn't have significant
results and these were women and these
were women who were taking prep and the
reason for this is that the people that
they think that the most of the women in
the trial were not taking it so when
they looked at people who said that they
were taking the medicine who reported
daily adherence they found that only
twenty to thirty percent of those people
in those trials actually had detectable
drug level so there's this huge
dichotomy between what people were
porting to taking the medicine and how
many actually took it and it was thought
and it and it is the reason pretty much
why these
I did not show the prep woods
efficacious the other theory that's been
thrown out there is that to not fear and
enter said beam build up to different
levels in the the vaginal verses of
rectal cavity so it's thought their men
to have sex with men the turnoff here
specifically as well as emtricitabine
build up to higher levels and may be
more effective for example preventing
HIV transmission through anal sex versus
an heterosexual transmission where they
build up to a little bit less levels in
the in the in the vagina this just sort
of drives home the point about adherence
when you look over these studies about
detectable drug levels you can sort of
the blue or people that were actually
HIV uninfected and the yellow or people
that had HIV infection but you can see
overall especially the I prex including
in the I prec study that the overall
adherence was pretty low based on
detectable drug levels and this is a key
point as prep to sort of implemented as
I'll mention in a few minutes this was a
study published about three weeks ago
actually in The Lancet that did some
modeling and some calculating the number
needed to treat based on the I prec
study data so they were asking the
question how many people do you actually
have to put on prep in order to prevent
one HIV infection now the number needed
to treat of course is dependent on a
couple of variables including efficacy
of the trial but for the I prec study
what they found was that the number
needed to treat was about 62 people so
that says that you'd have to treat about
62 people in order to prevent HIV
infection in one person when you look at
the highest risk group so receptive anal
intercourse is the highest risk behavior
for HIV infection that group you needed
to treat 36 people to prevent HIV
infection 1 HIV infection I thought this
is an interesting study and this is
what's published a few weeks ago in The
Lancet just to put that in perspective
as well this is some other things that
we do in medicine if you look at the
left-hand column these are some of the
preventive strategies that we do to
prevent death due to cardiovascular
disease the first column is the
intervention and the second column is
the number needed to treat if you want
to look at the very bottom aspirin
certainly we probably all know a bunch
of people that take an aspirin to
prevent cardiovascular disease you
actually need to treat 340 people with
aspirin in order to prevent one
cardiovascular death so this just sort
of puts things in perspective you can
see statins you need to treat about 126
people to prevent one death as well as
some of the other numbers there as well
I'd also like to remind the audience
this was something that I did a little
bit of review on the last few years
condoms we all talk about condoms as
being extremely effective in preventing
HIV transmission when you actually read
through the literature though and he
looks this studies and this is a
cochrane review consistent use of
condoms is associated with around eighty
percent reduction in HIV transmission so
this is this is just proves just shows
point that even condoms which we tend to
point to as a gold standard preventing
HIV and other STD transmission is not a
hundred percent so prep implementation I
want to start talking now about prep
implementation the United States
including in our state so when we think
about implementing a new intervention
there's sort of three different broad
categories that this can fallen in terms
of studies the first are the efficacy
trial so the clinical trials and those
are pretty much what i just showed we
know that prep is effective and a lot of
these a lot of the new interventions
will go through clinical trials of
course to show that they're efficacious
the second and third step really of
implementing an intervention are really
so-called demonstration projects and
finally implementation pilots or
clinical programs how do these differ
than efficacy trials well this is
looking at different aspects of really
rolling out the intervention in the real
world different things at least related
to prep that are being looked at
including delivery uptake adherence
risks and impact of HIV overall so as I
sort of showed on the previous few
slides the prep trials have really been
done in other international settings
have been a couple major set in a couple
settings in the United States but for
the most part the prep trials have
really been in international
international settings so that begs the
question you know
perhaps feasible in the United States is
it effective what populations do we
target cost issues etc so there's number
of different demonstration projects in
the United States I'll sort of show you
briefly go over these but these are
basically prospective observational
cohorts they're going on in a number of
cities as we speak it's really a limited
the really limited timeline so they're
talking about giving prep out for free
to populations in some of these
high-risk cities to high-risk
populations and really following them
for a period of time to see what happens
for people on prep one thing to note is
that it's a little bit different from
real world settings and that these
medications are often given out for free
and at least with a couple of programs
the United States when the sites shut
down their demonstration projects
they're actually no longer going to
prescribe prep medications not sure that
never that didn't quite make sense to me
but there's a number of different for
example STD clinics that don't
necessarily have a functioning I guess
outpatient medical system and once the
demonstration project ends are
essentially going to stop prescribing
prep that site and for people to other
sites so the demonstration projects are
a step of the implementing pathway but
they're certainly different than the
real world final point that we hope to
get to and finally I'll talk a little
bit about the last about clinical
programs and implementation pilots which
is one that we are starting at our site
in Rhode Island so prep so what are some
of the questions with prep
implementation one of the biggest
questions is delivery so defining and
targeting a priority population so this
relates certainly to the cost of prep
and how effective it is prepped is an
expensive medication but let me ask when
we pose the question to the audience
here how much does a single month of
truvada cost any ideas just to put in
perspective right if you go to walmart
there's a four dollar walmart list right
so you can go to walmart and get a
number of hypertensive medications you
can get a number of depression make
medicines you can get statins for four
dollars a month so how much does a month
of truvada cost any guesses
yep so the drug stores least in our
state they cost twelve hundred dollars
twelve hundred dollars a month so that's
pretty expensive and certainly not
something that our system can afford to
flood the entire population with prep so
something to think about so the question
is you know can we target prep in a
cost-effective way as well as people who
are most at risk second question is
where does this fit in with all the
other in with all the other prevention
strategies so in thinking about HIV
prevention certainly we're focusing on
prep today but the cornerstone is
actually testing right if you can't test
and diagnose people then allow these
other prevention initiatives don't
really make sense so when I think about
HIV prevention and I really love this
slide because I think it proves the
point is that these are all different
pieces of puzzle which prep is one of
them but certainly condoms behavioral
counsel in the the gold standard
ultimate cure would hopefully be a
vaccine but these are all different
components and where does prep fit in
and finally who is going to prescribe
prep are we talking about primary care
doctors which are prevalent throughout
the community we talked about HIV
specialists which tend to be centered at
major academic centers are we talking
about community clinics another
community service organization so these
are all questions are currently being
looked at and people are currently in
the process of answering once we've
identified the population we need to ask
a question do even people want to take
it you know is this something that
people are willing to take and want to
take is there a demand for it what are
some of the attitudes and stigma about
prep why would people want to or not
want to take them and finally can we
also target prep two periods in people's
life where they're most at risk
certainly if you think about our own
lives or the life of person there's
going to be certain periods in people's
lives where they're having higher risk
sex behavior or more risk of HIV
transmission right so it would be ideal
to be able to put people on prep during
these highest risk periods to prevent
them so it's not in terms of a long
continuous lifelong type medication this
is something that we've heard about in
our community and it's also coming down
the line it's the concept of a Truvada
[ __ ]
so this is the person if you're on prep
and you're taking Truvada people may
assume that you're basically whoring
yourself out and having multiple
multiple sexual partners so this is
something that we've heard in our
program and certainly something to be
aware of and I think illustrates the
concept of stigma already in this early
stage surrounding surrounding prep
adherence so as I mentioned before
adherence is really one of the key
concepts and a reason why I coupled the
other trials failed in the international
setting so if people want the medication
are they actually going to take it and
how are people going to take it there's
been some thoughts at people so there's
a number of different ways people can
take can take prep people in take it
every day of course but there's a number
of people that have asked can you take
prep if I so I'm not having sex all the
time I'm just having sex on the weekends
or perhaps just a weekend a month you
know like to go away I like to hit some
of the major clubs but I only do that
about one week in a month can I take
prep of a couple days before that big
weekend and a couple days after is that
going to protect me I've had a couple
people asked me that in clinic so
there's an these were one of them at
least was a medical medical person so
they understood you know the concept of
daily medication adherence these are
smart people so question is do people
have to take prep all the time for
people to be effective certainly we
counseled people to take it all the time
but even if they don't take it all the
time is it still effective this was an
interesting study based off the I prec
study again so this was published in
science translational medicine a couple
years ago if you look at the three the
three graphs on the left this is based
on something called a strand study the
strands study basically took 24 healthy
volunteers HIV negative gave them
truvada and looked and followed drug
levels so the the y-axis there are drug
levels you can see when people took drug
levels two times a week that blue bar
around 10 there that's how that's how
much the two not fear emtricitabine
levels they took it four times a week is
a little bit higher and of course that
they took it every day it was higher yet
when they looked at the number of cases
the people who had HIV in the I prex
trial there were three people out of the
42 that had detectable drug levels those
three there are in the red upside down
triangle
and you can see that that those levels
equate to about drug level of about two
times a week versus the controls you can
see which aren't even which are a little
bit higher but not but certainly not up
to every day based on some of these
numbers it was estimated that prep
efficacy was about seventy six percent
for two doses a week ninety-six percent
four doses a week and ninety-nine
percent for seven doses a week so again
the point here is that frankly you know
we don't tell our patients of this but
you probably don't have to take prep
every day for it to be effective so this
isn't something that's widely known or
Wylie camp counseled about certainly
it's hard it would be hard to take prep
for four days a week and be on schedule
but ideal but the point is is that you
don't technically need to take prep for
date seven days a week for it to be
effective risk so what are some of the
risks I'm a prep in terms of prep to
implementation well there's been a
couple reports out there a couple
concerns about risk compensation or
behavioral disinhibition so this is if
people are on prep are they going to all
of a sudden be having more sexual
partners are they going to double the
number of sexual partners and overcome
that protective effect of prep are they
going to start forgo condoms altogether
perhaps they weren't using condoms all
the time before but now are they going
to use condoms never and will that
overcome the efficacy seen with prep
finally there's a number of different
clinical side effects or words that we
concerned about prep one is side effects
this medication is very safe overall i'm
going to show you a couple things on the
next slide but there are side effects
especially a lot of the candidates for
prep are going to be otherwise normal
otherwise healthy adults younger adults
and the concern about putting some of
these people on prep long term is
something that we shouldn't do lightly
also in terms of drug resistance truvada
so the way that terada works is it is a
it is an HIV drug it is one that we
usually use in combination with a couple
with at least one other HIV medication
and so it makes sense that if we treat
people with to knock your emtricitabine
as well as another drug that when we
take it as prep it's going to build up
in your system and it's essentially
going to prevent
HIV from taking hold if you're ever
exposed given that the Tanaka recipient
is part of a three-door combination that
we normally treat people with there is
some some concern that you're partially
treating people and if someone were to
get HIV well on this drug that there
would be some resistance that has
actually not been borne out in the
studies it turns out that enough of ear
is a very hardy and very good drug and
and resistant this is actually rare
resistance is rare to Tanaka veer in the
clinical setting with people with HIV
it's also been rare in people who
developed HIV in these studies as well
finally we also worry about long-term
safety there's a number of different
concerns there and certainly there is
also concern for women who may be
pregnant taking prep this is a list of
the adverse events on the I prec study I
show just to illustrate a couple points
here the one the biggest side effect and
the thing that we counsel patients most
about is renal dysfunction so this is we
measure renal dysfunction by creatinine
level and in people who are on tanaka
vir long term you can see some
dysfunction of their kidneys and this is
something this is pretty much the major
point that I counsel people on before I
put them on prep I say the one major
side effect of this drug is it can
affect your kidneys it usually doesn't
do it in a cute manner it usually does
it over a period of months to years and
we monitor your kidney function over
every three months and we would stop the
drug before we see a decline but this is
sort of the biggest side effect that we
see the other thing when someone first
starts on prep people may have a little
bit of nausea and GI upset and again
this is something that goes away we're
not talking about dry heaves we're not
talking about vomiting but you can't see
a little bit of people usually described
as a little discomfort in their stomach
epigastric region and that usually goes
away after a week or two the last sort
of long-term effect that we that is
sometimes worried about is bone mineral
density this is something that if you do
some detailed bone mineral studies that
you can see over the long term we're
talking about years out of all the
people in our clinic who take Tanaka ver
it's very very rare and I I can't think
of a person that's actually had a bone
fracture due to being on tanaka bear
that being said certainly as people get
older and and have other risk factors
for osteoporosis osteopenia that may
become more of a concern however that is
listed as one of the concerns long-term
of people being on tenaya veer and
something to consider as well besides
those side effects the drug is also
extremely safe certainly as with any
drug people can have any side effect but
those are really the three main side
effects or concerns that people have
safety issues and people taking this
drug in terms of risk compensation I
want to present data based on two based
on to the major studies that have this
one is I prec study one is the partners
prep in both of these major studies
which follow thousands upon thousands of
people they did not see any elevated
risk compensation when people were on
prep so they did not find that people
are having more sexual partners and they
did not find that people were using less
condoms you can see here in the I prec
study this is partners in this is the
amount of receptive intercourse partners
in last 12 weeks you can see the number
of partners actually decreased both for
people on prep as well as sebo this is
the number of people using condoms or
receptive intercourse you can see the
number of condoms actually increase for
people in this trial likewise there is
no change in the average number of
unprotected sex / partners or in the
number of total sex partners per person
in the partner studies and the reason
for this is that at least in these
studies is that people are undergoing
intensive education and counseling when
they are on these drugs right so they're
coming in for study visits sometimes
every month and they're getting HIV
tested they're getting educated they're
getting counseled and so at least in
these major studies they have not seen
any change in risk behavior now that
being said we're currently doing a
qualitative study at our institution
before people get on prep and there's
been a number of qualitative studies
report in the literature of small
numbers of people in the United States
and there are people that are saying
you know oh my god this is great i'm
going to be able to get on prep I'm not
gonna I'm going to not have to use
condoms anymore so there are a number of
studies out there at least qualitative
lies that are suggesting that there may
be some element of risk compensation at
least in some people finally talking
about the impact of this is the ultimate
goal certainly ultimate goal of
decreasing HIV incidence and prevalence
in communities by implementing prep
questions that we have to ask are what
percentage of population do we need to
actually put on prep specifically of the
high risk populations and I'll show some
data from Rhode Island in a second and
then that has to really be balanced by
the cost-effectiveness I know at least
one member of your group David Paul TL
has published and is a much more of an
expert on this and I am to say basically
that the cost of truvada which is twelve
hundred dollars a month really has to be
based and targeted to people with the
highest risk in order for to make a cost
effective intervention so these are the
debt current demonstration projects
ongoing in the United States there's
been one that's actually been completed
this was a demonstration project in
Miami San Francisco and DC where they
basically looked at rolling out prep in
setting of STD clinics in fact this was
just published in plos one with the lead
author Liu Liu and they presented this
at Croy this year so basically what they
found and this was one of the settings
that I'm talking about where there have
a very finite period of prescribing prep
so the site in San Francisco they looked
at rolling out prep in the setting of
their STD clinic but they're not
planning on continuing that program past
the point of this demonstration project
and they're actually having trouble
finding community and people doctors in
the community to provide prep so it's
been a big problem with at least on
these early demonstration projects is
finding out how to continue prep once
they finish the demonstration projects
I'm certainly not going to go over all
these studies but just to show you that
this is sort of really the first wave of
prep
limitation in the United States the
longest studies probably the one at the
bottom it's I prex open-label extension
these are people that participate in the
i press trial and they're sort of and
they're following in an observational
way in the next couple of years to see
what happens once they know that they're
getting study drug is no longer placebo
blinded so what are we doing in Rhode
Island the smallest state in the country
so we were or we were awarded a 18-month
grant through the Gilead we applied for
for basically implementation project and
this is basically the step after the
demonstration project this is really
looking at prep in a clinical more of a
clinical setting and trying to integrate
all the sort of all the variables that I
mentioned a minute ago into sort of a
real-world clinical setting the people
that we're collaborating with and this
is actually to site project so I'm p I
and Providence Rhode Island at our STD
clinic as well as Jackson Mississippi a
collaborator down Jackson Mississippi is
leandra Mina and I'm working with Amy
nun up at Brown to for our site we're
also collaborating with ken Maher Fenway
Community Health who's providing some
logistical support and the goal was
really to implement prep into our STD
clinic and looking at processes and
barriers with that so when you think
about where and how to implement prepon
setting I'm really firm believer that in
order to reach some of these high-risk
populations an STD clinic is really one
of the ideal places to target and to
reach some of these people so I want to
just give take a brief segue now and
just talk about our STD clinic in Rhode
Island so we used to have a public STD
clinic that was funded by the Department
of Health that clinic was closed in 2011
due to financial cuts and in our state
at the same time and i'm going to show
you on the next slide we were seeing a
sharp increasing STDs in our state so
beginning in january two thousand twelve
basically a couple of us just decided to
open an STD clinic and when we first
started we were really looking at just
testing for syphilis and HIV and that
was because the syphilis rates in our
state had tripled over the last couple
years so we started basically a walk in
clinic friday afternoons we really try
to decrease barriers
to testing and we finally we were able
to add on gonorrhea and chlamydia and
the key about this clinic is that our
institution was able to support syphilis
gonorrhea chlamydia and we also got
support from the Department of Health
and this is what was going on in our
state and I know this is going on I
didn't have time to look up the
Connecticut epi data but I know this is
sort of similar to many other places and
states in the country what we basically
seen is really sharp increases across
all the other STDs in our state in 2008
our syphilis number of primary
infectious cases at simplest 425 the
last couple years it's been approaching
70 similarly with chlamydia we have
almost a thousand new cases over the
last couple years and gonorrhea has
almost doubled so our STD is in our
state we're certainly increasing we had
no we had no basically public STD
testing if you wanted to get an STD test
you basically had to go to an urgent
care center or a walking center so this
was an initiative that we out of our
institution that we started in order to
address the increasing STDs you also see
on the right hand side in red this is
the a lot of times in the clinical
setting if someone presents with HIV
they also have another STD this is the
the increased fold risk if you have one
of these SCT DS of increasing your HIV
transmission rate HIV in row around
again we're a small State we have about
4,000 people estimated to have HIV our
rates have really been stagnant over the
last 10 11 years you can see they have
come down slightly you can see from a
peak about 150 170 down to about 70 or
80 the last couple years but overall
they've been pretty pretty stagnant the
majority of these cases are in men who
have sex with men we've had a number of
initiatives that have dramatically
increased HIV due to injection drug use
you can see here the second line down
injection drug use have gone to
essentially we've had one or two cases
now a year we have an excellent clean
needle for exchange program in our state
that was spearheaded by people like Jody
rich Tim Flanagan Kerr Beckwith and
essentially really dramatically cut down
on HIV transmission dude enjoy
drug use really one of the success
stories in our state however at the
current time we're really seeing HIV as
many other places around the United
States due to gay bisexual and other men
who have sex with men has really
dramatically increased over the last few
years you can see for 2012 it's about
fifty percent but the other thing I
wanted to draw your attention to is that
very last line no risk reported we do
think that the majority if not most of
those people acquired HIV through
same-sex men who have sex with men so we
do think that overall based on the
surveillance data the numbers to show
that the rates of MSM are significantly
increased and probably much higher than
they actually are due to not being able
to capture some of the risk behaviors
the gold at our clinic were really to be
more of a commits based at our
outpatient academic hospital clinic but
the goal is really to be more of a
community clinic to being friendly
culturally competent we're really trying
to be non-judgmental respectful etc and
normalized sexuality we really encourage
people to ask questions that they
couldn't otherwise ask certainly anyone
else including primary care doctors we
do have a lot of people that come in who
don't feel comfortable to sketch
discussing sexual topics with their
primary care doctors for a number of
reasons there's also a big point in the
beginning to to make everything free
certainly cost is a huge barrier the
cost of these tests is actually probably
much more than you may think it would be
so let me ask a question to the audience
if you are going to get a chlamydia test
how much does a chlamydia test cost a
single chlamydia test any ideas
it's a hundred dollars one hundred
dollars so if you get a single committee
Test section $99 so if you get a single
chlamydia test our institutions $99 if
you get a single gonorrhea test its $99
HIV test is about 50 bucks syphilis test
is about 99 so it's essentially close to
four hundred dollars and some of the
guidelines also suggest oral pharyngeal
testing as well as rectal testing so
you're adding another two hundred
dollars for throat for gonorrhea
chlamydia two hundred dollars for rectal
testing the least cost balloon quite
rapidly and some of the guidelines also
suggests screening for people high-risk
individuals every three to six months so
you're talking over the course of year
several many thousands of dollars which
if you're uninsured certainly or
underinsured and have a high deductible
a lot of these are significant barriers
to STD testing we've gone from testing
about 10 or 11 per week we're currently
averaging about 40 to 50 per week these
are our numbers as of three weeks ago
you can see we're on still on an
exponential increase part of this is due
to advertising efforts and otherwise we
do expect these to plateau out hopefully
in the near future in terms of the
people that we're actually testing at
our clinic we actually started initially
as a men's clinic focusing on MSM over
thirty percent of our population is
currently MSM and seventy-five percent
overall our men our age demographics we
do have a number certainly when we try
to reach out to these people we do have
a number of different racial and ethnic
populations and we are penetrating the
younger age groups where STDs like
gonorrhea and chlamydia are most
prevalent this is just some behavioral
data from our clinic it is a super high
risk population sex partners in the past
year 4.3 thirty percent have used drugs
or alcohol during sex thirty percent
have reported a non miss X and these are
just what people are reporting they may
be actually on the low side thirty
percent have a prior STD only four
percent of rejection drug users then
this goes to sort of the population that
we're reaching out to and
nine percent I've been incarcerated five
percent forced to have sex two percent
exchange sex for money before we
implemented prep we did have we did ask
people have they ever heard of prep or
have they ever heard of post exposure
and this is sort of what we what we got
back and this consistent with other
places across the United States as well
turns out about a fifth to a quarter of
people across the United States have
heard about prep or pep and again these
are the people at least none are see
clinic that could benefit most in the
ones who are trying to target so there
is a huge education gap between the
population that we want to target as
well as the ones and people who actually
have heard of it our rate of positivity
for STDs in our clinic tends to be quite
high over ten percent of anyone walking
through the door has an STD overall our
HIV prevalence is one point four percent
you can see that our numbers here
reflect the overall trends in the
country in terms of chlamydia being the
most common gonorrhea and syphilis being
a little bit less common among MSM
population we are finding a four percent
Cyril positivity of HIV and eleven to
twelve percent of syphilis so super high
part of this is because we are pretty
closely involved and linked to the
Department of Health contact tracing
program so they do refer partners to us
specifically for syphilis we also
started initiative last couple years for
post-exposure prophylaxis we're running
a post-exposure prophylaxis program now
at our clinic people can walk in during
normal business hours and get post
exposure people can also call in pretty
much any time or doctor on call to get
the first prescription I'm giving the
timeline just to give a brief intro to
post exposure I'm guessing most people
have heard of it but for people that
have a sexual exposure they can start
truvada and another medication within 72
hours and it's been shown in the early
studies which dated into the 1990s that
if you take AZT at least within 72 hours
of being exposed to HIV you can reduce
your risk of HIV but about 80% we do
think that's much higher we're using
much more potent medication set and
we're not using just one medication
which some of those other studies to
just with AZ
t so post-exposure i think is a very
viable alternative to HIV prevention and
i wasn't going to say any more of it on
today in terms of prep implementation
what do we actually do another STD
clinic so everyone when they first come
in to our clinic is screened for risk
behaviors and this is for the purpose of
statewide surveillance reporting as well
as to offer education and counseling to
individuals re alone when they first
come in r asked to fill out a one-page
sheet about some different risk
behaviors we then perform a rapid test
as well as test for other STDs syphilis
is a blood draw gonorrhea chlamydia our
urine test and during the time they're
waiting for the rapid test we do perform
education and counseling as well as
discuss prep with the with the with a
client we have a one-page sheet that we
go over that is meant to be more visual
just to discuss what prep is and our our
strategy our clinic was has been to
really discuss prep with all MSM so
we're sort of targeting MSM in Rhode
Island and the reason is twofold one is
that the majority of people in our state
by far our MSM and the second is is that
we want to really disseminate
information so we have a number of MSM
so when we talk about MSM it's certainly
diverse population we have people that
come to a clinic or monogamous I've been
with the same partner for years and just
routine coming in for the routine test
and we also have people that are
reporting a hundred partners are silly
sexually diverse population our thoughts
were in initiating this program were to
really that we really want to talk with
everyone about prep just to advertise
get the word out and increase awareness
in the community if someone is
interested about prep we do schedule a
follow-up appointment with myself or
another doctor to prescribe prep if
someone has barriers like different cost
issues we have someone to call them
trying to work through some of the
different insurance issues and that's
been one of the barriers as well is
getting people insurance so the the the
financial barrier sorrow haven't been
paying for the medication again I
mentioned the medication was twelve
hundred dollars a month that can be
covered that's covered by most insurance
plans it's covered by all insurance
plans if you have on
if you don't have insurance we actually
there's actually a program through the
drug company where you can get free
medication indefinitely for prep so
getting the medication actually has not
been a problem the problem has been
actually paying for all the labs paying
for the doctor visits and paying for
everything else isn't covered
traditionally under with the medication
that's really been the challenge in
terms of the financial barriers the
things that we're looking at an
implementation project are the things
mentioned previously one of the biggest
ones that hasn't been looked at much in
the demonstration project is the
financial barriers and that's something
that we're also focusing on cataloging
really in detail why or why not someone
can afford it what type of insurance
plans they're using we are also specimen
banking so with every blood draw when
someone comes into the clinic we are
saving blood for use later part of
that's going to be to check for drug
levels if someone ever converts as well
as to look at resistance testing if
someone ever cerro converts i want to
just show some very preliminary data it
seems like everything in the HIV world
now is now a cascade so I figured we
will make a cascade out of this what we
basically want to show is the
penetration of prep into our STD
population so if you start at the top
this is for the month period from
November through februari we had 502
people testing for HIV stds out of those
thirty two percent were msn again I
mentioned again that MSM are the people
that were educating prep to about prep
of those we were able to educate
sixty-two percent so this is in the
setting of a busy STD clinic there are
some people that walk out there's some
people that just aren't interested don't
want to be talked to we were able to
have counseling sessions specifically
about prep these counseling sessions are
probably about five minutes to about 60
to bruges son of the MSM of those fifty
percent were interested in prep ten
percent actually had Pony appointments
scheduled for prep and five people
actually ended up on prep at each point
there's a number of reasons why people
were we're not interested or other
barriers so sue
prep and those are what we're focusing
on addressing and catalogue in terms of
our implementation project these are the
people that were referred through our
STD clinic there's also been a number of
different people who have come in from
other sources who are in our prep
program we have five people through the
STD clinic we have an additional 15 that
we put on prep from referral sources
primary care doctors etc etc so today we
have about 20 ish maybe a couple more
and we're putting on about two or three
people on every week we have pH patients
scheduled so future directions to finish
up here we are going to launch a
statewide campaign to promote HIV and
STD testing the tile of it is going to
be do it right you can see the RI stands
for Rhode Island it's highlighted that
was my idea and you can see and you can
see it's meant to sort of present in a
visually appealing way as well as simple
way we're not trying to reinvent the
wheel here we want to give people sort
of different ways to protect themselves
including prep and again as mentioned
before I do firmly believe that prep is
one of the tools that we use and certain
people can benefit but should not really
be the main strategy or the main push in
terms of HIV and prevention in fact the
main strategy should be get tested get
tested routinely obviously people once
you know your HIV infected we can get
you into care on medications etc etc so
the cornerstone of HIV prevention is
really just encouraging routine testing
however again for some people prep as
well as pep and nicks and other
Prevention's interventions can be
beneficial also we're certainly looking
for other clinical partners this is part
of my point to be me being here today is
that we are looking to expand prep and
it would really be nice to get a network
of HIV prevention clinics which include
prep in southern New England so
certainly if anyone's interested about
the clinical or other aspects of prep
programs please feel free to talk to me
or Elaine and that is all thank you very
much I'm going to end there
you